[Music]
in bad service news
oh damn submitted by Joe Molly and
pooper scooper Paul that's an important
job we got a lot of dogs over there a
woman says she was dragged from her
truck after refusing to pay a nail salon
over poor treatment still gotta pay
though you cannot tip but you still
gotta pay right is this America no yeah
this isn't my mouth then in San Antonio
oh the police say that she does have a
right to not pay for the service Oh what
she should have done first is contact
them the police
apparently that kind of time that's what
they told her that's just the right
thing to do oh I see
it's not a time doing the images the
right didn't yeah maybe I think where
you got a nosy [ __ ] Richie knows I got
it you know all right so I'm gonna show
you guys a video clip of this woman
getting interviewed uh uh her name is
Emily she's experienced that's what you
were like who did dragged from a truck
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I want them
to pay for what they did what they did
was not right she refused to apologize
and then she ended up saying somewhere
you are the problem I said after that I
grabbed my stuff
meth I walked out
went to my truck she says the manager
opened up the door to her truck demanded
payment and when Henderson refused tried
to drag her out by her leg kicked her
with my other leg and then I kicked her
in her face and then she fell back I
asked her to get out of my area more you
know a different way and then she said
no pay me and that's when she tells me
I'm gonna yank this off if you don't pay
me anybody can talk anything you didn't
want it to
what she said she said anyone could say
anything pretty much she's like that's
her story yeah yeah but she didn't want
to comment further
the manager damn who do you believe yeah
then usually the pretty one wins right
that's how it works in court with any
now thing I kind of believed the order
yeah oh really
yeah mother duck why cuz you're just
that's like usually the customers are
just freaking out that's like the
minority yeah I mean yeah like if I
didn't know the law I would think that
that's stealing like if you get a
service done and then afterwards you
don't pay for it and you walk away
that's to me that's like that's like
getting a massage and then after you get
hit with the bill you don't pay for it
you walk away I don't feel more relaxed
I'm not paying [ __ ] up haircuts I'm
like what the [ __ ] is this but I still
pay I'm just like I'm just not coming
back again yeah
but the difference with nails is you can
undo that like you can take all right
most of the issues yeah if it's acrylics
you can take them off it's paint you can
take it off so while I leave before
rectifying the situation to technicians
because then when apparently she's
saying that when she when she complained
to the manager that the manager told her
you're the problem and that's when she
said [ __ ] this I'm leaving and that's
that but then there was someone sushi
that sounds kind of realistic it sounds
about right though cuz I believe Gina it
happened to Gina where she all she
wanted was for them to shape her real
natural nail keep the length and then um
the lady just started clipping she's
like no what are you doing I want I did
took me months to grow this out you're
[ __ ] it up so then Gina being nice
the way she is she's just like [ __ ] it
I'll make it work with your short ass
nails and then they started like cutting
her cuticle all [ __ ] up made her bleed
and stuck she's just like oh dude so she
paid but they should just put him on
social media that's
yes uh there it seems like Emily
reviewed this nail place and gave it a
one-star and then someone commented on
that review this Plus this wow that's a
lot of reading you ready for that you
ready for that I'm ready for it it's
still babe please all right so it says
first of all princess you got the whole
story twisted you came in for a backfill
and asked redacted to get to do a whole
layer on your nails now that's more work
than just to fill itself the only time
you need the whole nail to be covered is
when it's thin and in your case it
wasn't so she refused second I know
redacted she's harmless because you were
already mad at the situation you came up
and talked to the manager and so when
you sat back down to get your nails
painted blank didn't slap you but brush
the dust off your nose with her hand
dramatic much princess now the manager
had the right to follow you and get the
money because you can't just not pay for
the service that has been done on you
it's like eating your food halfway in
and saying it's disgusting but you still
have to pay for that food and she didn't
drag you out I saw the whole thing she
just stood by the door when you decided
to kick her in the face and her son
happened to be there so what could he do
stand there and watch his mother get
kicked so he dragged you out the client
that was sitting next to you also told
us what happened and explained the whole
thing in detail every business owner
tried to perform their best they treat
you good or bad depends on you you try
you trying to get your whole family to
write bad reviews on here just because
of your experience is too petty I hope
you enjoy the rest of your day and
reflected back on what you did and how
you lied to everyone and the police
officers yeah so was the Sun that dried
her and she she just kicked the mom in
the face so that's what that that's that
personally she admitted
kicking her in the face though she said
that in the interview but she said she
was pulling her this is justifiable it
was not the fence yeah and apparently
like she's saying or someone saying that
that person that wrote everything I just
read might be working for that no please
it sounds like they're a family member
like getting their back I think the only
way to really figure this situation out
to have a rematch
the manager in her and I'm right there
with you fight it out yeah have a card
or scenario so we could see like what
really happened we just put them in the
cage now I want to see the car flip the
cart because how do you pick someone in
the face unless they have you turn this
way yeah she might have had a really
high kick she's tiny she's in a trust
yeah you're like lifted the Asian ladies
real small so it's kind of like yeah but
she would still have to be turned the
right way the conversation
oh my god [ __ ] be a judge it's like a
here both sides like oh really know what
happened now tell me your signs and the
[ __ ] plan is [ __ ] thickening over
some milk yeah imagine there was a judge
like that his judge and a murder like oh
your side your honor
oh my god what you gotta say about that
TV show that they had a judge that was
like that that's how I was watching the
[ __ ] hold tannic on Shane Dawson [ __ ]
I was like the first video was like oh
[ __ ] man [ __ ] [ __ ] this dude who is this
[ __ ] good times [ __ ] [ __ ]
this guy and then I was like oh wait one
to Tana [ __ ] [ __ ] you've been lied to
the all all [ __ ] YouTube and you've
been [ __ ] with youtubers and then you
go back to all no but she's right though
the [ __ ] good times guy I just go
back and forth
emotional roles it was man I feel like
that's how this is - because now I first
heard her story I was like yeah I know
how I know how sometimes there's a
there's a culture clash and and
sometimes there's rude behavior in Asian
businesses because they don't know how
to operate in the Western business style
sometimes it happens I've been told that
I ordered the wrong [ __ ] when I did
order the right [ __ ] you know they try
to convince me that I forgotten [ __ ] I
[ __ ] know what I ordered cuz I've
been craving it the whole day I want to
[ __ ] that bad [ __ ] but I you know that
[ __ ] happens so I'm like hmm I do trust
her but then I also know that there's
always some shady ass entitled [ __ ]
customers that demand everything yeah
and I also know that there's people that
try to get away from paying by causing a
scene there are you want some free [ __ ]
and they know they'll get free [ __ ] so
they'll just [ __ ] cause a scene to
get free SH like whatever I remember one
of our Vegas trips we were eating at the
serendipity place and then there was a
group of people that had all these
hamburgers but they were more than
halfway done with them and then they're
just all went up to the window or
whatever yeah and then they were they
were complaining they were making a
scene about how disgusting the food was
I don't know it's because of people like
that
that's not pay for the hamburgers what
is the rule on hamburgers can you eat
like a quarter of it and then get a new
one
hmm I think if you take more than one
bite you're [ __ ] me too for what if
you need a confirmation more than two
bites yeah unless you're like you ate
half of it in a roach showed up or pubic
hair oh yeah yeah or like a [ __ ]
three flies one flies okay depends you
know like like if you ate 75% of that
[ __ ] and then some [ __ ] Roach tail
came out oh weird I mean I mean a rat
tail or something else usually if I eat
more than 50% and I find something I'm
already like too late I'm
you move it to the side I'm like I know
that's a hair I'm finishing do I just
eat so fast that I don't notice you know
but sometimes I find the hair or I find
like a fly or a bug and I just find the
hair always convince myself that was my
hair I just call like did anyone else
see it all right no all my hair I think
it's the big bugs that I mind
definitely like a fool fly a scorpion
another smaller flies like the fruit
flies like that yeah that should that
[ __ ] goes in food like that's normal
right so I just pick it up throw it to
the side
how's the barbecue you know we had a
barbecue this flies all over the food
you know I [ __ ] it we're all you know
this [ __ ] like like the watermelons were
eating only flies are on that
[ __ ]
are you serious the fried chicken answer
oh we go internal we talk to each other
like I'm just sitting there I see a ton
of flies come yeah and the people let's
go get the watermelon a fly back away oh
I'm still covered with the ham it's fine
enough yeah I think it's perfectly fine
[Music]